Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. It's
2192. David P We haven't heard much from Eric
from Massachusetts lately. He's this COVID
conspiracy theorist who's been calling off,
calling in, off and on for the
last 2 to 3 years. He's back,
and he's accusing me of things that I never said.
Speaker 4: Hey, David. A third from math.
I get the idea that you are frothing at the
mouth to have lockdowns and masks again.
Speaker 1: When did I say that?
Speaker 4: And have everybody the economy
be crippled, like you said, in your ivory tower?
Speaker 1: No, I want the economy to do well.
So my stocks and bonds go up.
Speaker 4: And dictate what
everyone should do wrong. You know,
like I told you, I was a leftist.
Democrats have no problem with progressivism.
Why do you think I found you? But when
COVID hit, I knew they were lying. Right.
Speaker 1: This guy was a progressive. Then
all of a sudden, there's a virus and he becomes
an unhinged right wing conspiracy theorist. Sounds
more like it's a mind virus that infected him.
Speaker 4: But to do with politics, it's about
lies and truth. You know what I mean? And like you
said, oh, they're not going to start something for
the midterms. And then they said it. What we are.
Excuse me. Now, the midterms. The common lockdowns
are coming. Get the fuck out of here.
Speaker 1: All right. So anyway,
I don't support any of that stuff. I've
said nothing about it. Eric is very,
very delusional, and sometimes I think he's
reacting to things other hosts have said. Like,
I think sometimes it's just he's confused.
We are going to talk on the bonus show today
about the lawsuit against the PGA for suspending
golfers who played in the Saudi funded golf tour.
We will talk about Josh Hawley's vote
against Finland and Sweden joining Naito
and we will talk about Georgia residents
being able to claim embryos as dependent
on state taxes. Listen. If nothing else,
they're being consistent. If that's a person,
you should be able to claim an embryo as a
dependent. I mean, it's at least consistent. All
of those stories and more on today's bonus show.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Well, Alex, I don't know that
you're in a position to really say much
about the bonus show right now. You can sign up
at join Packman dot com. We will see you then.